moi-même factory vient de compléter une
installation pour le musée d'art de
pékin le tout entièrement à distance en
temps de pandémie
cette firme montréalaise réputé pour ses
grandes oeuvres mais sa créativité au
service des musiques note gageure ce que
les gens vont voir le goût de se revoir
de vivre des expériences en public alors
plusieurs de nos projets actuellement
sont misent beaucoup sur des projets qui
fonctionne bien en distanciation qui
fonctionne bien dans l'est dans la vraie
vie des rencontres impossible pour le
moment au québec
le mcs a donc décidé de bonifier son
offre en ligne en misant sur l'aspect de
la performance et sur la réflexion qu'on
essaye de mettre en ligne en fait des
contenus qu'on juge pertinent est
important pour le moment où on peut
passer une bonne à réfléchir assure
moment historique n'est pas seulement
une crise sanitaire mais aussi une crise
de justice sociale le centre fitoussi
très dynamique performance en ligne
location de casques de réalité virtuelle
pour regarder les oeuvres à la maison
pour l'institution ne succès passe par
une mise en contexte de ces contenus une
simple captation selon moi c'est parce
il faut qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
vienne qui viennent l'entourent il faut
pas voir l'aspect numérique comme un
danger pour le lieu physique pas du tout
je pense que ça doit être complémentaire
mais l'expérience physique est vraiment
est vraiment essentiel
et même s'il est impossible de dire
quand les salles d'exposition rouvriront
certains comme le musée des beaux-arts
le centre des sciences ou le musée de
l'ingéniosité joseph armand bombardier
envisage déjà de bonifier et de rendre
plus sécuritaires leur visite grâce au
numérique comme ce projet phare des
projections architecturales sur le
plancher mais qui nous permettra en
temps réel de détecter le fameux de
mètres de distance au québec de rendre
ce d'une façon un peu plus funky ou
iphone on a des systèmes jusque
maintenant tu marches un océan puis les
poissons s'approche de toi mais quand tu
es trop proche de quelqu'un d'autre qui
vont s'éloigner la semaine prochaine de
nombreuses firmes participeront à
l'événement ob montréal pour réfléchir à
l'avenir de la créativité numérique et
avec leur art apporter un peu de lumière
ici nabi alexandre charti radio canada
montréal